three two
one a spacecraft intentionally crashed
into an asteroid on September 26th oh
wow as part of a roughly 325 million
dollar mission
all right
the Collision is part of NASA's double
asteroid redirection test also known as
Dart this is the first for for humankind
so why did NASA crash a multi-million
dollar spacecraft into an asteroid and
what will scientists learn from it
there are currently over 1 million known
asteroids according to NASA they vary in
size shape and composition and move in
different orbits around the Sun some
even cross paths with Earth's orbit but
typically don't pose a threat to our
planet but asteroid impacts have
occurred throughout Earth's history
scientists believe an asteroid impact
led to the extinction of dinosaurs in
order to test one type of technology
that could mitigate a possible future
asteroid impact NASA launched dark three
two one
and liftoff of the Falcon 9 and dart the
dart spacecraft launched into outer
space almost 10 months ago the school
bus sized spacecraft traveled millions
of miles through space and eventually
collided with an asteroid about the size
of the Washington Monument
this is NASA's first ever planetary
defense test mission planetary defense
in general is aimed at finding out
what's out there figuring out if
anything is out there that we need to
worry about and when we need to worry
about it Andy Rifkin an investigation
lead on the dart team identifies
asteroids and develops methods to
mitigate the risk that opposed to planet
Earth he says this real world experiment
will prepare defense methods against
future hazardous asteroids it's the
first time that we are rearranging
Celestial body's orbit dark targeted the
binary asteroid system did the most
which is composed of two asteroids
didimos the larger asteroid and its
smaller moonlet dimorphos this is what
scientists call Kinetic impactor
technology which involves using
spacecraft designed to deflect a
near-earth object to change its orbit so
that it misses our planet
according to NASA Dart collided into the
asteroid at roughly 14 000 miles per
hour and the impact occurred around 7
million miles away from Earth
but navigating a small spacecraft leaves
little room for error you can't sit
there with a joystick and steer yourself
in that fast this is why NASA created
allows the space
wrecked itself in
little was known about the composition
of dimorphous before the Collision only
pixelated telescopic and radar images
have provided small clues about its
surface but now scientists will be able
to study images of the crash which were
captured by an Italian cubesat called
leecher Cube the images will help
scientists determine what kind of impact
Dart had on dimorphos including a
potential crater on the surface of the
asteroid
scientists are also researching how the
impact changes the asteroids orbit
before impact it took to morphos
approximately 11 hours and 54 minutes to
orbit didimos but that is likely to
change now we don't know if it will
change it to more like 11 hours and 42
minutes or 11 hours and 46 minutes in
order to measure a change to the orbit
rivkin and his team will collect data on
the asteroid system's light curves which
are measurements of a Celestial body's
brightness at certain intervals using
the light curves scientists will be able
to compare the new orbit to the old
orbit showing how much impact Dart made
during the Collision in October 2024 the
European Space Agency will launch a
mission called Hera which will reach
dimorphos in 2026 to conduct detailed
post-impact surveys on the asteroid hero
will advance scientists understanding of
dimorphosis internal properties and the
outcome of the dart test though Dart is
only a test and dimorphos isn't a threat
to planet Earth carrying out a real
world test will inform scientists
whether this type of planetary defense
is a reliable option against future
asteroids headed towards Earth we don't
want to add to people's anxieties we
want to demonstrate that we can handle
asteroid deflections
[Music]